Um, hi everyone. Uh, I'm Dong from Palto
Networks. Uh, I'm a machine learning
engineer working on um, threat
intelligence. So, today of the talk,
I'll just talk about how we build a
threat intelligence uh, from getting
open source intelligence data. Um, I
think many of you are working with open
source intelligence data. Um, have used
some of it. Um the best thing about open
source intelligence data is free. Um but
is is it really free? Um it's it's out
there in the wild but you have to gather
it into a structured format that you can
use it uh for downstream task easily. Um
so for for people using open source
intelligence data a lot of things are
just like threat reports published by
different vendors. Um you can read them
you know occasionally trying to look out
for things that might related to your
company protect the threats that you're
looking for. Um but reading reports uh
take a lot of time. Um so some people
just okay we can maybe have a
subscription to a in uh intel feed and
just gives you a bunch of stuff but
those things are usually like indicator
fees. Indicator fees are good if you
just a plug and chug maybe to your EDR
and just check for these things. Um but
what the really thing lacks is the
contextual clue of what this indicator
is about. And that's just the uh butter
of the open source intelligence data
lies in the um unstructured data out
there. Um so there we're tracking about
over 200 different uh valid sources
across the internet and this thing can
crowd maybe like 10 uh 10,000 reports
each week and this is not for possible
for anybody to consume. Um and there are
uh different same events um talk about
by different vendors but they are like
overlapping things they talk about and
the things this vendor talks about the
other vendor didn't talk about. So it's
very important to look at this uh open
source data holistically so you get a
better picture of of what's going on out
there.
So the problem really is um you can't
possibly look at everything out there.
Um it is it is timely intel. you want to
read it at the time it's first published
so you get the best up-to-date
information but you can't keep track of
that kind of stuff every day. Um so what
we think is uh why don't we make this
thing uh reverse the problem a little
bit uh we think about okay what people
use uh threat intel for and uh maybe we
take a proactive approach let the user
uh think about um how they want to use
it. So we want to make it like an sort
of a question answering type of
scenario. Uh let's say I want to know
about uh the the different malware used
by AP29 and I just want to get an answer
out of it or other cases I have seen
these kind of indicators showing up uh
in my logs. Um I want to see if anybody
in the open source community has done
any research on these things and give me
a better picture of what's really going
on uh out there. Um but the problem is
uh you can't possibly feed all these
reports uh in the LM and LM sometimes
doesn't have update information. Um so
you need some sort of a structure to
contain all these kind of threat reports
into a structure format and that also
fit into your threat modeling.
So something that naturally comes into
the structure is basically a knowledge
graph transformation. Um cyber security
data are in nature interconnected with
each other. Um there's different
entities you can trace them how people
how threat actor uses them how they use
the malware what are kind of indicators
are you seeing in your logs uh and what
you know what victims are being uh
attacked
um so so so now we basically need to
think about how we kind of extract this
information um out of this uh reports
and when you think about their intel uh
ontology or structure first thing uh
sticks uh how many of you guys have used
sticks and and Love it.
All right. I mean, we we have one here.
That's that's good. Uh I heard a lot of
uh different stories obviously. Um so we
the problem with stakes is like very
machine readable. It's not really for
human to ingest and can get really long,
you know, very quick. Um so what what is
lacking is I think the uh we don't want
something that's entirely structured. Um
that's not very good for human to read.
Neither does it good for actually AI to
read. AI likes like unstructured text.
Um but you can't really give it too
much. So um this ontology essentially of
knowledge ar gives it uh what's called
like a semistructured data format where
you have some constraint on what kind of
information you want but you still
retain the unstructured data to give it
uh context and clue uh to explain this
in.
Uh now where we're at it uh actually
let's take a look at a example
um here from this threat report uh
published a couple weeks ago about this
beyond trust critical vulnerability. Um
this report it takes about 11 minutes to
read. Um it talk about the malware
vshell uh spark rt different uh
different details about the
vulnerability. Um it talks about the
scope of attack. Uh talk about the V
shell activity malware here. Um it also
talks about uh the historic context of
previous beyond shell vulnerability and
at the end um it has just a list of
indicators related to this attack. Um
for for human to read this this report
and then also just to extract
intelligence out of it um can take a lot
of time. reading 10 minutes, extracting
it out, putting somewhere um maybe
another 40 minutes. So, it's actually a
lot of uh work that we don't want our
threat researchers to do. We want to
want their times to spend on something
more useful. Um so, let's take a look at
a example of what the kind of graph look
like if we just struck everything out of
it. So in this medium I guess report u
we're able to get like over 100
different entities out of it um and also
over a 100 different uh relationships
out of it. Uh we can zoom in a little
bit in the graph. Um let's just take a
look at the like the vshell uh malware
here. Um it has like different infection
vectors things related to this malware
extracted from the report. Um it also
it also has uh talk about like a
previous campaign that uh related to
this. Um
there's that here is like extracted
vulnerability. Uh and
here you can also see uh like a previous
uh thread actor also exploiting the uh
beyond shell vulnerability in uh 2024.
Uh now let's zoom out of this uh graph
and look at uh how it possibly related
to larger picture in the graph. Uh so
now we're just like expanding uh on
relationship uh from nodes extracted
from the report and then trying to see
what are some other entities also um
related to this thing. Uh so for example
this like an attack pattern uh mentioned
here is about ingress 2 transfer. Uh we
see this this being used across uh
various different campaigns. uh v
various different um thread actor uses
this. So this give you a much granular
picture of what's going on out there.
Now u let's actually switch back. Um so
so how do we really extract this kind of
uh information is really dense. It's in
essence I have like over 100 different
entities. LM has been very good at doing
stuff, but then doing stuff reliable is
uh you can't just like one-shot this
thing uh from the get-go. So basically,
we kind of just uh split it up over
multiple steps trying to make LM extract
this. Uh what we first start is like
basically having a skeleton uh extractor
essentially acting as a router uh to
look the report see if there's anything
worthwhile to extract. Um if you see
something worth spell essentially just
routes uh to different uh extraction
component and then it basically tracks
detail information for each uh entity
types. Um for for most of things we
trying to ground it just to extract
exactly how it phrase in the report. Um
but for things like attack pattern
usually they don't have the mater ID in
the report. So you have to just try to
look at the um attack behaviors there
and try to introduce uh induce what my
attack pattern is. Uh turns out actually
LM has a pretty good knowledge of the
entire my base. But if you just asking
it okay what you know attack pattern
inside it's actually giving it's like a
fuzzy recall. Um a lot of attack
patterns may be similar. So it actually
produce a lot of noise. Um so what we
kind of did here is um like how you
think about things let lm extract
behavior let extract couple of candidate
u potential um attack pattern and let lm
read related um attack patterns from a
knowledge base and it will basically
correct itself to land on a final attack
pattern for that behavior.
And lastly is about a relationship
extraction. um when you have like a 100
different entities um the relationship
basically just explode. Um so what we
did is we just basically con constrain
uh to a set of uh to a set of triplets
of entities and relationship mappings
there and let lm basically route what
which um relationship can establish and
like I was just showing uh in the graph
here um it actually gives a description
uh like for what type of uh relationship
it is instead of like constraining just
to a verb uses this description is able
to give you a contextual clue is this is
how it's actually been used.
Um so next steps we're talking about
like how okay we land this architecture
the most important thing about this all
this AI uh application is how you do
your evaluation and this is the only
indicator of quality of your data
especially for thread intelligence um
like a lot of things for this project we
didn't really have a benchmark uh to
start with there there wasn't really any
good benchmark on just extracting threat
entities and relationships out of long
lengthy threat reports so this is
something we kind of have to start build
from the ground up. Um at the beginning
we were just doing fact checking trying
to see if LM give something makes sense
something's you know crazy wrong and
just also validate with external sources
uh that are out there. The problem with
just uh building LM evaluator and
external sources is um you are
constrained to the knowledge that's out
there. If you know something that's
wrong, you can build a LM evalator
trying to watch for that. um if you know
there's like a malware out there, you
can cross check but something if it's
missing in the report or it's like
attack pattern from behavior, you don't
really have this information readily
available. So you still have to use uh
some sort of human knowledge uh to hear
uh to curate this data set. So basically
we try to you know make the best time of
our threat researchers. So we really
make a quick iteration in terms of how
we scale the data set. uh we have
started with a small data set curated by
threat researcher and we want the model
to try to memorize it as much as
possible and we do inference on another
batch of data and with maybe two or
three iterations uh the model is able to
get 90% correct on most of things is and
for for third issue they really just
have to look at it uh and just check so
very minimal effort in just really
annotating the data from here.
Um so as you get to you know hundreds
and thousands of entities like you can't
possibly look at the reports and trying
to see what's wrong with it. So we're
just trying to using uh LM to curate and
then conclude uh the through a automatic
pro optimization process. So there's
like a lot of works on this but actually
uh it doesn't quite exactly uh work here
is um a lot of things LM might change in
this iteration. Say they've seen this
false positive. They generated a
hypothesis of why this is wrong and they
added something to prompt and
automatically this thing is changing the
previous prompt and is causing it's
actually like a loop that you couldn't
get out of. You fix something, you got
something wrong, you fix something, got
something wrong. So in this loop so
basically what we did is we constrain in
a prompt in an area where only LM can
change and there's some section where
human can change. Um so this actually uh
reduced a lot of things where
essentially you pick up uh this thing
and you drop another thing is able to
improve upon upon here. Um another
interesting uh thing we noticed from
this is uh basically during the uh
reflection aggregator is is basically
summarizing uh multiple reason why this
is wrong and trying to get a new
proposal out of it. Um actually Ellen
find a lot of things. we have a
inconsistency verdict uh from the
annotators. Uh so across report maybe
this thing was they think is a malware
they think this is a tool or they
extract this campaign is not. So
actually automatically discovered
inconsistencies uh within human uh
researchers. Um if you ask somebody to
look at this report um they may look up
different things. So we we had this
thing uh another loop basically have LM
list out a lot of uh interesting
conflicts uh that is observing and just
we send it like to the uh started threat
registers and let them fight this out.
Um
so basically we covered uh how we go
from unstructured data and to construct
this knowledge graph. Uh now we can talk
about how we go from the knowledge graph
uh to some answers that you really care
about.
Um so basically we started something
simple. We just want to let the agent
capability to interact with the uh
knowledge graph like some human would.
Um so basically you would just start
from a pivot point um either from like
searching for a node and then you just
basically walk the graph from that node
trying to find related information.
Um and now actually let's take a look at
the report on beyond trust that we just
looked at. Uh I just want to ask a
question about okay uh can you just look
up the most recent uh beyond trust
vulnerability? How is this been
exploited? Uh give me a a tech chain of
this uh exploitation. So basically the
the LM agent is able to just search for
indies in beyond trust. It found the
vulnerability and it find the most
recent one. Um then it basically just
get the subg graph from this node to get
a full story of what's going on with
this vulnerability. Uh then it basically
get the details about the vulnerability.
Uh it's able to get related thread actor
to this vulnerability. It's able to get
other campaigns that are related to this
thread uh this vulnerability. And here
it gives out an attack chain uh that's
happened how to exploit this
vulnerability.
Um also is worth noting is just that it
also gives you uh sources of which node
this is able to find uh this information
which this gives a lot of trust to to uh
to LM not to rely on its model knowledge
whereas relying on curated information
from threat reports
and at the end essentially gives you a
investigation graph just just show you
what step it look at and what entities
are looked at uh to arrive at this
answer. Um now let's actually look at
another example uh taking a look at the
thinis capability uh of this knowledge
graph. So if I want to look at things
from a higher level look at okay what
malware does AP28 uses um is able to
look at the AP28 um it actually look up
multiple thread actor here because for
AP28 it has multiple aliases and for
different reports they may mention this
alias and this alias but essentially
it's talking about the same thread
actor. Um and it's basically looking for
uh basically multihops of how this
thread actor correlate to different
malares. Um it's doing like semantic
search and now here is basically doing
look up a bunch of related malares to
this thread actor and also getting a
subgraph of the thread actor aliases.
Uh and here at the end it basically um
arrives at a bunch of different recent
malware that's used by this thread
actor. um and different sort of tools
that use it. Um now let's take a look at
a a more multihop question. Uh basically
what vulnerability does AP28 exploit and
is there any other thread actor group
exploit this vulnerability as well. Um
so now is already has the pre some of
the previous information. So it's only
trying to get the neighbors that have
exploits relationship. um looking for
from the exploit relationship from uh
different aliases thread actors uh and
doing semantic search. Um here it based
now you have find pivot from the thread
actor to the vulnerability exploit. Now
I just take another hop trying to see
what thread actors are related uh to
this vulnerabilities. Um and at the end
it basically finds bunch of list of uh
vulnerabilities uh and also tons of
different thread actors also exploiting
the same vulnerability.
And this one basically lands like a much
longer investigation graph because you
have to look for a lot of more entities.
Um let's also look up another question.
Uh maybe you want to find is there any
relationships between two thread actor
groups maybe different malares. So here
we're asking oh um is there any
relationship or connection between ATP28
and ATP29.
Um now it's basically already has enough
information about 28. Now it's looking
up in this AP29
is trying to find a path that's
connecting between the two thread actors
in the graph and it's looking for co-
occurrences. Co- occurrences essentially
um they want to look for entities that
mention the same report. So this gives
LM a chance to look for things that are
not in the ontology but from the report
and basically it it gets the step graph
from the u thread actor 28. Notice
there's like doing two different calls
because there are multiple aliases uh of
thread actor 20 2029.
Uh now here it basically gets the answer
talk about their common tooling common
infrastructure uh uses um and there's
shared strategic targeting um basically
type of victims they they they like to
target um and then also national
attribution um they're both attributed
to Russian GRU that one is uh Russian uh
foreign intelligence services so they
from the same uh geographical location
um And at the end it has a list of
investigation graph. Um that's the end
of our presentation.
[applause]
>> Hey uh firstly thanks for your
presentation. Uh appreciate it. Um I
think it's really impressive that you
all have someone like yourself on staff
uh as a as a very senior experienced
data scientist to help build tools like
this. So props to pan for that uh
question. Um how do you qualify the
outputs uh and like the correlary the
obvious cores like what are your failure
rates for responses like being incorrect
analyses?
>> Um so I guess there are two things right
so I think the most important evaluation
we're doing essentially is making sure
the graph extracted is correct. So if if
your agents are relying on this graph
and this graph is trash then it's like
trash out. you really can't fix anything
from that point. So basically we do a
very like rigorous evaluation um like we
have hundreds of thread reports in our
data set and we're just making sure LM's
able to get it reliably each time. Um
basically for for also there's like
iterative uh decoding essentially if
there's something we test it with a
report with like hundreds of indicators
and our extraction is able to um
iteratively get the indicators out of
the report. Um so basically just invest
heavily in evaluation. I would say like
more than 50% of time I spend on just
building evaluation u just fighting with
sweat researchers a researchers b okay
you guys disagree you know get in a room
let's fight this out so a lot of this is
also just massaging the data and art of
just making a you know a comprehensive
evaluation also another thing is um this
is ultimately decided by the user of the
data. So we have talk about uh with
multiple teams inside Paulo or threat
like uh you know URL team different
threat researchers malware team. So we
want them to use data and it correlates
with their data to see if it makes sense
and obviously checking we have our
internal data sources. So this is OENT
uh we also have internal data sources
that are doing cross checking.
Um so uh you spoke about the sorry you
asked the question around APD28 and
APD29 right but at least I didn't see in
the report anywhere where it said both
are named bear
right like I mean like if you ask an LLM
something I mean like without giving the
knowledge if you ask it the least it
would say is oh both are named bear
maybe they're related right but you I
didn't see that in your report. So did
you do anything specific to make sure
that those kind of conditions or well
technically in this case it's kind of a
hallucination honestly like did you do
something to avoid such a hallucination?
>> Sorry what kind of a hallucination are
you talking about? So like when you
asked about the APD28 versus APD29 is
there any connection right
when you just run it across a normal LLM
right like which doesn't have any
information about the knowledge graph
the least it would say is both are named
bear
both have the name bear in it
>> fancy bear and the other one is
>> some other bear so maybe they are both
related is what it would say
>> but in your report it is not there.
>> So I'm asking like did you do anything
specific to achieve that like where it
doesn't hallucinate in that aspect?
>> Oh I see. Yeah. Sorry I didn't get the
first time you're saying like they they
might just say something similar to
their alias names, right? Like something
I guess nobody really cares about from
that. So I think it's just really having
a knowledge base where your LM can
constantly get access to. So that's why
we're building this knowledge graph. We
want the model just really ground on the
knowledge graph itself instead of
relying on model knowledge which can be
wrong. Um also another things like when
when just like basically outputting this
um it is giving like things like this
right this like like okay it's not it's
not showing on the part basically for
each statement has a bracket at the end
it says basically where it gets the
information. So basically we just ground
LM to the sources uh of the knowledge
graph.
Oh, great talk. Uh, I wanted to ask
about the for the eval system and the
framework you put in. What kind of
monitoring are in place to feed that
back into the feedback loop?
>> Uh, monitoring do you mean like during
training stage or during like
inferencing stage?
>> Uh, actually both.
>> Both. Okay. So, I guess like for
training is like kind of like what I
mentioned there. Uh, we have like just
building a automatic prompt optimization
process that's like constantly
monitoring this. Um we actually just
interesting fact out of that like newer
model actually doesn't necessarily
produce better you know benchmark
>> that that was my question.
>> Yeah maybe I think you're
>> that's the curve you observe all the
time.
>> Yeah actually also another interesting
curve is like thinking model actually
doesn't do better than non-thinking
model. Um that's like a weird
observation is a thinking model is think
seems to think too much mostly rely on
model knowledge where actually the task
we're doing is like okay we try to
reduce the model bias as little as
possible just rely on the sources at
hand. Um but for for for inferencing I I
would say like we we have like LM as a
judge you know running in production but
those things I guess is secondary to the
evaluation uh data set.
>> One more question.
>> Hi uh great talk. Thank you. So how do
you are you looking at the overall
metadata of your processes in place? So
for example the community in general is
not putting in attribution. For example,
Notepad++ they come out and they blog it
was the Chinese but they don't have any
indicators. It hits bleeping complete
computer and now everybody believes that
it was the Chinese right. So are you
looking at overall data as to like the
attribution and how the the in general
the community is not publishing quality
reporting and how that's skewed over
over time.
>> Um
>> does that make sense?
>> So I guess like
another question one two questions I
think you asked like how is the quality
of the the open source intelligence and
other question is like uh what kind of
attribution are we doing? you know like
as there my theory is the hypothesis is
that the community is just not producing
quality reports now right so over over
the years so again I gave a case example
notepad++ all of a sudden it's the news
bleeping computer everybody believes
it's the Chinese meanwhile we don't have
indicators from the source zero patient
right so are you seeing in your metadata
this kind of shift where we're not
getting quality reporting from the
community.
>> Yeah, I see. So, this is actually
interesting question. I guess we haven't
looked too deeply into but just just
thinking on the spot. So, if you're
making an uh I guess like a threat actor
attribution, you know, or counter
attribution in your report,
>> if you are doing a good reporting, you
would have a lot of evidence on it. If
you're just like making a claim at a
news report like you said and you're not
having a lot of evidence to back it up
in a graphic what kind of kind of shows
essentially if you make this claim how
many nos are there this gives you some
sort of cal uh evidence calibration and
also we have like internal um thread
intel that's also doing factchecking.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you so much. Thank you.